in the rice paddies of rambukana you can
see the roots of sri lanka's food crisis
it's planting season here but look only
a few square yards in the center have
been cultivated the rest is untouched
last season's crop gone to seed because
farmers can't afford or even find fuel
for tractors to turn the soil
ravindra is still nursing this year's
seedlings at home until he can begin
cultivation which may need to be by hand
he says the fuel shortage is compounding
a disastrous government decision last
year to ban chemical fertilizer imports
it was supposed to save money and
protect sri lanka's dwindling foreign
currency reserves but the country's now
paying a high
what happens in these small paddies
matters because they don't just feed
families they feed the whole country but
with yields down or perhaps cultivation
not happening at all farmers livelihoods
are threatened as less surplus to sell
into the market in a year the price of
rice has trebled
[Applause]
fuel shortages are hobbling the entire
economy they rush to fill up whenever
and whatever they can here frustration
at price rises sparked protests that had
tragic consequences last month when
police opened fire on a demonstration
killing one man and injuring at least a
dozen more
srilata's fifteen-year-old son sarhan
was among them shot in the arm and body
as he watched the protest after school
[Music]
foreign
in colombo's wholesale market life goes
on despite a state of emergency imposed
this weekend by the president to
suppress protests
and prices keep going up
food price inflation has been dramatic
and it's unavoidable for most leaks are
up 30
green chiles 40 okra ladies finger 50
and potatoes 60
all in a year
there's a risk on on food shortages
because of the high prices and we even
don't have reserves to import
and at the same time the crops is
expected to drop because of the
fertilizer uh fertilizer issue it's for
urban poor
and urban community of course there's a
challenge i think the option is
countries like china and india had
assisted us with some food supplies
that this verdant abundant island should
face food shortages may be the starkest
measure of the trouble it's in
paul kelsey sky news in rambukana sri
lanka